Okay, let's go next to our caller from the
eight 43 area code.
Who's calling today from eight 43.
Hey, this is Chris myrtle beach.
Hey Chris.
I haven't been to myrtle beach since I was
like 13.
Is it still the same?
I guess?
Yeah, still the same rock grew up down here,
but um, yeah.
My question for you today is I appreciate
you taking my call by the way, but my question
for day is, which can have all the candidates
you think would be the most likely to defeat
Trump in 2020
I don't have any personal opinion on this
beyond what the polls say.
The polls say that Biden would do well against
Trump.
It sounds weird to me.
Like, I don't know.
He's just very low energy.
I don't know how he would deal with Trump's
attacks.
The polls say Biden would do well.
Bernie would do well.
I think what?
Like right now it's looking okay for all of
them based on the polls.
I don't feel like I have a special insight
into it.
Yeah.
I, I liked the girl from California, but I'm
thinking that Boston probably is the best
chance right now.
I'd be like, wow.
My girlfriend, California, you mean Carla
Harris
to what
you mean?
Kamala Harris from California?
Yeah.
Okay.
The girl from California.
Maybe a little condescending, but yeah, I
know what you, I know who you mean.
Yeah.
Sorry.
But yeah, my own met button seems pretty cool,
but um, yeah, that was just my question then.
What part of the party do you think will be
pivotal in showing up for the boat as far
as like people showing out
w Pitt with like who do I think is most reliably
going to show up or who if they showed up
would be most beneficial to the Democratic
Party?
Yes.
Okay.
Well those are two different things.
I mean I think, listen, the people that are
going to show up, the people that are going
to show up are the center left older Democrats,
they always vote.
Okay.
I mean just history.
We know the data.
They always vote, so they are going to vote.
They are more in favor of Biden.
The x factor is going to be, does the young
progressive wing show up when Trump was elected,
it was like huge activism.
A ton of people activated new people in politics.
Will their enthusiasm from two years ago carry
through to where they actually go and vote
in November of 2020 I don't know.
That's always the question mark.
Yeah, that's it.
Yep.
But yes, that was just my questions.
[inaudible] you taking my call?
All right.
Chris from myrtle beach.
Appreciate it.
Uh, hope the water's warm down there and all
of that stuff.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up.
I'll get back to the phones right after the
break.
Don't hang up.
If you're holding new thing, make sure you're
following me on twitch at twitch.tv/david
Pakman.
I'll be right back after this